good morning and gets Tuesday and as you
can tell from the great speckled walls
behind me in a stunning turn of events I
have found myself in an airport so Hank
since brother 2.0 started in 2007 I have
flown more than a rotation security
required oh no it's my pleasure to
cooperate with that federal security
requirement my only request is that two
minutes from now you let me know about
the same requirement so Hank since
Brotherhood 2.0 started in 2007 I've
flown more than 400,000 miles and as a
result I have a lot of perks always
smoking prohibited that's stunning
I would never guessed it I got I want to
take off my shoes when I go through
security because I've been pre-cleared
by the TSA I get to board the plane
first because I have a gold medallion
thing I can even go to the fancy airport
lounge although I don't because it's
extremely depressing in there but by far
the most important perk is that when the
plague comes that is going to devastate
humanity I will be among its first
victims if that stuff never starts with
people like watching CSI at home it
starts in airports and I've always said
if there's gonna be some human ending
apocalyptic event I want to be right out
in front of it like my zombie apocalypse
plan become a zombie as quickly as
possible I don't want to watch all the
people I love slowly be overtaken by the
undead also I usually get to sit in
first class so most people think that
the people who sit in first class are
like rich people who paid a lot of money
for their tickets and sometimes that's
true but most people who sit in first
class get to sit up there because they
fly with the same airline all the time
and the airline wants to like thank them
or essentially bribe them to listen up
in frequent flyers as you're walking
past the first-class people to here like
middle seat in the second-to-last row of
the airplane I want you to remember
something you may think man those are
the fancy people those are the people
who've got it figured out but no you
with your seat in the middle of the last
row you haven't figured out because well
it's true that I enjoy many perks as a
result of having spent more than 500
days in the last six years in the
company of the great speckled walls
there are also some disadvantages I
think I remember once I was falling like
Dayton Ohio and I sat next to a guy who
had like not gold status or platinum
status of diamond status but like
diamond platinum elite silver plus
status like he'd flown like ten million
miles and I was so impressed I was like
man that is an awesome status that
you've got there hey oh comedians like
yeah you know it's pretty amazing status
but you know what it cost me a marriage
like I do realize this is the first
World least of all first world problems
when I have to go thirty thousand feet
into the air and observe the majesty of
Earth on a regular basis the thing about
traveling all the time is that while
it's true that you get to be the first
person to dine like the rabbit plague or
whatever and that's huge you also have
to spend a lot of time away from your
family and that sucks which is why Hank
I am so excited that this is my last
trip to the great speckled walls until
August when I go to VidCon I think I
cannot tell you how excited I am to
become an infrequent flier I'm gonna
make lots of videos and I'm gonna work
on my new book but most importantly I am
going to hang out with my family which
hopefully includes you in the Katherine
egg but you've got to come here because
as previously noted I am NOT flying Hank
in the comments of my video from last
week where I cook dinner with Henry a
lot of people are like you're such a
great dad and I hope that I am a good
dad but if I am it's not because I can
like make some jokes while holding a
video camera and overcooking asparagus
heck when I was back at my job
[Music]
why do people always have to get Paige I
have never been paged
I have spent 500 days in airports in the
last six years and never once have I
needed to be paged shmurda light is
changing I have to move because the
Risen Sun is too bright in my losing
eyes ultimately Hank I think a big part
of being a parent is being around so I'm
gonna try that out for a while
what it is this what why did no one tell
me about this I walked through the
airport what how did this happen has
this been going on the entire video
great now the people in the airport
think that I'm extra crazy because in
addition to holding a video camera in
front of myself I've been half naked the
entire time oh my god I have to go hide
somewhere Hank I'll see you on Friday